welcome to this video playing G role do
you roam and came here i'm going to
decline that again when i recently took
that pawn it was just too awkward should
be 4i guess so it's not a maraca see buy
it yet but quite often it will be 1 and
so getting rid of that bishop this make
and quite some sense ok folks 8 yeah
maybe I can play 95 and then maybe night
see for this typical thing ok he wants
to trade this ok I think in general I
welcome trades and the structure that
reduces any possible dangers to my my
king and i can do things on the
queenside maybe i will take why not then
queen bee six attacking be too yeah so
night c4 is that possible I guess yeah
that should be a decent structure maybe
he can go if five no it didn't uh-huh
but perhaps sorry for that so II five no
see going for h4 is that the idea
ok possible route age five I've got now
the right moment it's not clear that
this move was necessary but seemed so ok
yeah it's not really threatening
anything I try to provoke weaknesses
with a 3 here that would weaken them a
little bit and then I go Quincy for
taking a form and try to get to the to
the Queen side ok so he wants to
sacrifice I'm going to check that porn
that's h5 it's not really doing anything
at least I don't see what it is doing
fatigues f takes two sixes so quite
easily saving
maybe I even could have taken that you
fought porn queen bee one check yeah
that would have been really good
actually Queenie for would have covered
g6 as well and when I can but anyway
this is okay he really has no
compensation for that poem okay so i can
go queen f64 queen g7 or other stuff
Queenie five is also possible yeah it
actually looks quite good run attacking
that rook and attacking h5 FG 6hg six I
can play after six sir no problem there
Luke age three look at seven and then a
possible Queen f4 seems good
nice really just a pawn down it boils
down to this simple fact could have take
it you for again I should do that one
time really I could have taken that
point for basically not much again I'm
able to do that but well I don't I don't
really see what it's not working their
butt
I can't anyway
going to get before in let's not do
anything like a pre mafia lk well so I'm
going to take that end game in no time
it's got be to ng to hanging
yeah it's a totally awesome that will be
two pawns up and a double rook endgame
and no counter play um check white
resides it was just a little bit to
relax there about giving up that dick
porn we have a I think equal position
around him this is this yeah I know
that's okay when t amo take stakes here
I was thinking if I've might be an idea
to open up the position film but well
it's equal there it's not not much the
same g3 we need six yeah and here he has
to do something I guess and not give
away that porn he went hy that's just
not working the engine is actually
pointing out this move that's
interesting intending rook age four and
after f6 it wants to go if five that's
really interesting what is that point
here i am kim when okay yeah look g6 is
a draw it here he's actually able to
check and late form for a win whoa okay
so Ruby Falls interesting I do something
like that he's got a sorry he's got a
four amazing yeah because that's awkward
interesting so that was really strong he
went there between eight who he I know I
should just take that second porn check
I already saw that a bit too late and
can really do that there's nothing
really happening i'm covering that
critical g 6 square came back here and
here i think i'm basically winning if
i'm not blundering something i should
should win the champ check i should win
this position rather easily as it
happened ok well thanks for watching